the ocean is a Mysterious World humans
know more about the surface of Mars than
the floor of the ocean and the sea
creatures who live there well even the
ones you have imagined you've imagined
them wrong take the mighty giant Kraken
bloodthirsty monster Sinker of ships
where are you even getting this Krakens
are majestic creatures and Noble
protectors I'm just Ruby Gilman normal
teenager for Generations Krakens have
protected the Seas keeping us safe from
the most power hungry and dangerous
creature of all the mermaid yes the
mermaid but people love mermaids
they do people are stupid I'm Chelsea
mermaids are selfish vain narcissists I
am quartus yes Queen the worst of them
all
hey are you okay
I know your secret you're a kraken
hiding is a human you really gotta go
now and soon everyone will know the
truth
are you ready for your destiny I just
want to live my life
you have powers beyond your imagination
this is your moments Ruby
I'm not gonna hide anymore
Grandmama I want you to teach me how to
use my Powers camouflage
super speed body armor let's see what
you're capable of
yes they do pack a wallet
you're just a dumb teenager
I'm a flipping mermaid knock knock no
matter what the challenge a kraken will
always answer us all it's time
go big